parents tu sais que tu es le client
idéal pour ce qu'on a inventé dans cette
émission qui s'appelle lentilles
portrait chinois
ce serait une maladie un cancer
encore un beau concert généralise les
grecs mais encore que le pari reste des
réductions français qui avait une façon
de faire la sécurité sociale à la carte
on parie sur de trop mauvais et si on
gagne à rembourser le triple le nouvel
assist rapporter gros mais concerne je
n'ai jamais il ya une maladie
cardiovasculaire ou le pensait voilà les
grands cerfs sida il pas une forme
claire
donc non il y en a d'autres actions
voiture étant une troisième donc tu
partirais tu t'es irait en fonction de
ce que tu as décidé plus ou moins cher
et les autres frais remboursés moi je
suis un truc qui est un gros servent et
si tu étais un microbe
c'est un petit microbes qui décroche un
petit fils comme un champignon intrus on
invite si c'était un vis à vis la
masturbation c'est tellement triste
est ce que tu préfères et c'est ce qui
reste quand tout le monde s'en va
c'était une guerre une guerre non un
mouvement un mouvement
moment guerrier ou en soutenant la
révolte du ghetto de varsovie je trouve
assez exaltant vient ouais le seul truc
face chaque fois que les civils casas
gallo militaire de varsovie son père oui
oui mais cela dit ça n'a rien à voir si
simplement que j'aime pas trop les
militaires un accident un accident
ferait pas une essence très bonne
réponse une cicatrice non je dirais pas
et d'une belle vous voulez la voir et
une pas alors c'est qu'à manger elles
sont la toute récente l'après feist ou
par les chapeauter les pompes et si tu
étais un terroriste pour finir qui
battait un terrorisme en fin bouillon je
suis pas tort et c'est pas du tout sinon
je ne vois pas comment c'est la merde
quand même non non je fous là merde
toute la merde dans la dans le fumier
l'année les fraîches